well I think with the onslaught of
celebrity and our fascination with
celebrity at such a high pitched level
that fashion which is kind of it's
younger sister or second cousin that
idea of celebrity designers are very
glamorous they dress starlets the red
carpet the handbag business has gone
crazy so the general population has
really understood fashion way that it
never has in generations before and it's
reached I think a kind of celebrity semi
celebrity level where the designers the
models and even you know Anna Wintour
and the devil wears prada have become
large celebrities in their own rights
that has elevated the fashion show to a
semi you know paparazzi event where
people can be photographed famous people
go to the shows famous models are seen
in the collections and designers that
are world-renowned and famous are seen
going in and out of these shows in these
tents the seating is a slightly medieval
process but yes everybody likes to get
the best seat that they can and a lot of
editors are very unhappy if they're in
the second row or the third row which is
basically considered Siberia so if you
are an editor of good standing you
usually have a front-row seat at the
major collections the major shows in New
York for sure New York leads it off and
I must say I think that's probably an
appropriate place for it to be New York
is a solid place for fashion it's a
consistently good place for fashion
however it's not the innovator it's not
the real creative juice that we all seek
and that the retailers seek to really
get ourselves excited about the stories
we're going to put in our magazines and
the clothes that are going to be bought
and purchased in and ultimately bought
in the stores particularly this season I
don't think it was one of New York's
best seasons I think it was a very beige
season and with that comes a certain
sort of venality there's nothing that
glamorous and dramatic about the color
beige so I think that's kind of
metaphor for a little bit with the
season is however we do have a star and
he's a major star he continues to shock
and rock and push us forward that's Marc
Jacobs and indeed his both his
collections this time we're very very
powerful his marc jacobs collection
which I just looked at in person and up
close to feel the fabrics and to see the
accessories and to really see what he'd
done was in pastiche of ideas and styles
and fabrics and color and was kind of
Laura Ingalls and Little House on the
Prairie on crack I mean it was a crazy
apron dress ruffled skirt but done in
Lorax and lemay so again mark pushes the
boundaries he pushes the buttons he
dares to mix fabrics and colors and
silhouettes and probably because he just
doesn't care that he's free to do what
he wants and he never repeats himself
he's got favorite things that he does
there's always a somewhere a seller all
influence I would say but clearly done
Ella mark he likes to push people he
likes to shake it all up you know he was
a famous famous for his grunge
collection in the early 90s and he
continues to really rock our world but
it's great and this show was vibrant
colorful electic a real mix kept
everybody on their toes yet again and
his mark by marc jacobs collection which
is his younger line was just as
delightful and enchanting and if I was
you know 18 to 25 Matt was sort of my
demographic and my age group I would be
running running running to those to his
stores and to those boutiques to get
those clothes so he really gets you
excited he really makes you want to buy
clothes he makes you want the handbags
fantastic everyone said the it bag is
over nobody needs groovy bags anymore
that's all passe forget it mark has just
made us all realize that there is
another it bag and he had about five
that were spectacular in his mark
collection so I think New York is glad
to have mark I'm certainly personally
and professionally happy to have him he
makes it exciting he's on a level with
the best designers in Europe
particularly Paris as well as Miuccia
Prada in Milan and really keeping
fashion exciting and interesting and
pushing
you know I I admire Anna Wintour so much
because because of her unbelievable
power and and because she does a
fantastic job in vogue but particularly
in this question because she really
tries to promote and spend a large
portion of her time and Vogues time and
effort to promote the next generation
it's just a really hard business to be
that competitive in you know these guys
are coming up with four to six
collections a year that creative process
is unbelievably challenging I mean think
about an artist that has to come up with
a whole of four to six times a year I
mean they just don't you know they they
do the same thing they move they evolve
over time over a decade over five years
these guys are asked to kind of reinvent
the wheel create as well as learning
their trade and trying to have viable
businesses so it's really hard I think
for the young generation to come forward
to push forward some of the kind of new
up-and-comers that have been around
several seasons I'm disappointed to say
that they faltered a little bit they're
not able to keep going with the kind of
expectation that we all put on them but
but Anna and the vogue fun and the CFDA
the Council of Fashion Designers of
America really are trying to support
fashion at that starting level to really
give these young designers to support in
the financial cash that they need to
continue and also to sort of offer kind
of mentoring program but no as far as
New York is concerned that's not it's
not been a kind of season of newness but
London which is happening as we speak
right now is and continues to be a real
interesting place where all those free
ideas and kind of crazy eccentric things
that the English are known for are able
to come out and have created
unbelievable talent so I think London is
really the place where you watch the
next best
generation of designers